okay here we go
switch over to the night camera we're
using these incredible cameras
it gives us the ability to see all this
action at night
we're seeing an almost daylight image
[Music]
it's amazing to film stuff that's never
been seen scientists don't even know
what happens
these two male cheaters start hunting at
night time which is unseen
behavior one of them's starting to run
in the amount of nights we've been out
here
i can't believe we actually got that
shot finally it's
brilliant we wanted to film the softer
side not many people know that they live
in these really lovely family groups
we're hoping that we can show a world
that no one's seen before
we're only beginning to understand the
strange things that take place
at night it's all very well doing
this sort of thing in daylight we're
trying to take it on at night
that adds layers and layers of problems
you obviously look down you can't see
what's happening
uh yes that looks amazing
yeah that's great wow
this is definitely one of the hardest
shoots i've been on
about 30 out here
having to constantly look out for
predators like bears it's a big worry
wow i actually see teeth marks the claw
marks
[Music]
key here to filming is when they move
you got to stick with them but in a way
you're not interfering especially if
they're hunting
i'm really really happy to have seen
that oh that's so cool
turns us humans into nocturnal animals
being able to sit out here with him in
the dark is pretty
incredible to see into the life of an
animal we can reveal
how magic the night world really is
that's really amazing to see
you